الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيش بما
سماه خانقه دول العالم الغنيه وشركات
الطاقه الكبرى البلدان الفقيره بمعدلات
فائده جشعه واسعار وقود مرتفعه جاء هذا في
مؤتمر الامم المتحده الخامس المعني
بالبلدان الاقل نموا الذي تستضيفه العاصمه
القطريه الدوحه ويستمر حتى التاسع من
الشهر الجاري وقال غوتيرش انه يتعين على
الدول الثريه تقديم خمسي مليار دولار
سنويا لمساعده الدول التي وصفها بالعالقه
في حلقات مفرغه تعرقل جهودها الراميه
لتعزيز اقتصاداتها وتحسين الصحه والتعليم
ويعقد المؤتمر المعني ب 46 دوله مصنفه ضمن
الاقل نمو في العالم عاده كل عشر سنوات
لكنه تاجل مرتين منذ عام 2021 بسبب جائحه
كورونا
تخفيف وازمات المعيشه يزداد صعوبه يوما
بعد يوم مع تسارع الحرب في اوكرانيا
وارتفاع اسعار الطاقه والغذاء وتاثيرات
النزاعات والجفاف والجوع والفقر المدقع
النتيجه عاصفه لتكريس الفقر والظلم ومن
غير المقبول اعاقه الدول الفقيره بسبب
قرارات تتخذ خارج حدودها لقد صممت البلدان
الغنيه نظامنا الماليه العالمي لمصلحتها
الى حد كبير وهذا هو السبب في اصرارنا
بشده وبالتحديد على مجموعه العشرين من اجل
اصلاحه الدول الاقل نموا محرومه من
السيوله والعديد منها محروم من اسواق راس
المال بسبب اسعار الفائده المتوحشه
وتضطر لانفاق مزيد من الحصص من ايراداتها
لخدمه الديون القاسيه
ومن جهاته اكد وزير الخارجيه القطري الشيخ
محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثاني التزام بلاده
بدعم البلدان لقد نموا في التصدي للتحديات
الملحه واشار الى ان بلاده خصصت جزءا
كبيرا من مساعدات امائيه لهذه الدول
استنادا لسياسه دوله قطر الثابته وايمان
بالعمل القائم على مبدا الشراكه والتعاون
مع المجتمع الدولي فاننا نؤكد حرصنا على
مواصله وتقديم الدعم لاقل البلدان نموا
بالتعاون مع اخواننا واصدقائنا وشركائنا
حول العالم حيث تم تخصيص جزء كبير من
مساعداتنا الايمائيه الدوليه لهذه البلدان
وانطلاقا من ايماننا بضروره الى اكبر قدر
من الاهتمام للاستجابه لاحتياجات اقل
البلدان نموا جاءت مبادره دوله قطر
لاستضافه مؤتمر الامم المتحده الخامس
المعني باقل البلدان نموا